[Musique]
comment amazon est elle en train de
faire main basse sur la planète que vu
jeff bezos ce qui n'aurait déjà quel
avenir la multinationale veut-elle nous
imposer et accueille brille c'est
aujourd'hui que sort en salles le film
le monde selon amazon une coproduction
franco-canadienne une enquête
documentaire sur la position dominante
d'amazon amazon qui expédie 5 milliards
de colis par année le film porte sur les
ramifications les tentacules d'amazon
dans l'économie une entreprise qui crée
des emplois mais qui en supprime par la
bande dans les entreprises concurrentes
alexandre et sheldon et recherchiste et
assistant réalisateur du documentaire le
monde selon amazon bonsoir bonsoir c'est
un film donc franco canadienne tournée
ici au québec mais aussi en france aux
états unis en inde notamment pourquoi
faire ce film mais parce que amazon
occupe une place de plus en plus
importante dans nos vies amazon fait
pertinent des géants du web qui est en
train de réagir en tant qu architecte de
notre futur collectif et on en connaît
très très peu je pense en règle générale
auprès de la population
on connaît amazon n'entend qu'un son de
magasin et en ligne
mais malgré amazon c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus qu'un magasin un magasin
en ligne extrêmement power vous parlait
pratiquement de monopole dans le film
en quoi c'est ça devient un monopole ben
les les statistiques on a un à
disposition nous indique que c'est
indolore sur 2 en commerce électronique
qui aux états unis qui va directement
amazon donc on parle de 50 % donc
un monopole c'est pas tout le temps
évident à définir et on s'entend pas
nécessairement sur cette définition là
mais pour nous je pense que quand amazon
obtient une place importante dans la
manière que ce marché le fonctionne la
vente en ligne mais dans d'autres
marchés notamment d'infonuagique on peut
commencer à parler de monopole
vous êtes assez critique là le film est
assez critique du modèle d'amazon
d'ailleurs amazon ne donne pas
d'entrevue mais nous à part fait
parvenir des informations par écrit ou
aujourd'hui en disant on peut pas parler
de monopole la grande majorité des
ventes au détail 90% se fait encore dans
des magasins de brique et de mortier et
le pourcentage d'amazon en commerce de
détail mondiale est d'environ 1% alors
que notre pourcentage dans le commerce
de détail américain est inférieur à 4 %
10 amazon ne sont pas un monopole du
bien je pense que le congrès américain
déjà il peut tout à fait d'accord avec
ça il ya des audiences en ce moment aux
états unis pour qu'ils parlent carrément
d'appliquer la loi antitrust sur amazon
mais aussi sur les autres géants du web
elizabeth warren aux états unis près
candidate une candidate aux primaires
démocrates parle elle aussi dans sa
campagne de bricquebec et pour nous tous
les intervenants qui ont parlant que
pour tous les intervenants mais
plusieurs intervenants d'un documentaire
no 10
si ça sent le monopole 6 a agi comme un
monopole c'est probablement un monopole
est d'ailleurs par rapport à ce qu'est
amazon dit nous on n'avance pas dans le
film que y'a que le commerce en ligne
est en train de supplanter le commerce
au dictateur au détail mais clairement
c'est une tendance qui va en
s'accélérant et qu'un impact réel donc
vous êtes allé un peu partout vous êtes
allé l'argent à la rencontre d'anciens
employés n'est ce pas et d'experts
vous avez visité des installations
également vous êtes entré à l'intérieur
on n'a malheureusement pas eu cet axe-là
par contre
l'auteur qui est à l'origine du projet
du film lui avait travaillé pendant
trois mois dans un entrepôt d'amazon et
sa guise en fait le point de départ du
documentaire donc ses expériences en
tant qu'ouvrier d'entrepôts justement
dans le pic saisonnier avant noël
avez-vous tenté d'entrer au gouvernement
oui on a fait plusieurs de ces amazones
dit aussi que c'est possible de visiter
les installations il est tout un
programme de visites dit amazon
oui c'est oui en effet lyon un programme
de visites mais de rentrer là avec une
équipe documentaire c'est une autre
histoire c'est une autre histoire je le
dis vous avez des images de l'intérieur
mais ce sont des image corporative des
zonages sont accessibles publiquement
hockey à maison dit dans son
documentaire dans votre documentaire
qu'il ya de fausses informations sur les
conditions de travail des employés
cheval de sol parce que amazon a réagi
quand même assez fort aujourd'hui à
votre document c'est presque flatter
vous en exactement finalement ai donc
dit que parce que vous vous laissez
entendre que les gens travaillent comme
des robots comme des machines finalement
vraiment un travail à la chaîne
amazon dit nos conditions de travail
sont bonnes pour le type de travail
on paie un bon salaire il ya des
avantages sociaux et également oui donc
mais ce que je peux répondre à ça c'est
pas plus tard que cette semaine y avait
une grande enquête du magazine the
atlantic qui montrait qu'en moyenne y
deux fois plus de blessures graves dans
les entrepôts d'amazon que la moyenne
des entrepôts aux états unis parce qu'il
ya plus de morts parce que la pression
exercée sur les ouvriers d'amazon est
beaucoup beaucoup plus forte pour avoir
notre notre livraison à un jour ou deux
jours ou même dans certains corps une
heure ou deux heures gratuitement
s'impliquent qui est un humain quelque
part kiwis se fait traiter un peu comme
un robot et puis les témoignages en fait
ce qu'on rapporte dans le film s'est
basé sur des témoignages qu'on a récolté
ses potes dans notre opinion à nous
c'est les témoignages qu'on a récolté
auprès de plusieurs plusieurs employés
de l'amazone et puis ce qui nous
rapporte par exemple c'est la
surveillance constante dans les
entrepôts sont constamment surveillés
géolocalisé en tout temps et on décote
extrêmement sévère à respecter et un
système d'avertissement par lequel s'ils
obtiennent trois ou quatre
avertissements
ils peuvent être envoyés donc c'est une
culture d'entreprise qui est gay qui
rapportée par cette récente de pression
dans les usines
dans les entreprises amazon n'a pas
voulu vous donner d'entrevue n'ont donc
pas d'entrevue quelle preuve vous avez
que les pertes d'emplois et des
fermetures d'usinés qu'il y à des pertes
d'emplois et des fermetures d usines qui
sont principalement attribuable à la
présence et à l'expansion de la zone
donc c'est pas des preuves qu'on apporte
c'est encore là c'est une entrevue avec
une experte qui dans le film qui
s'appelle stacy mitchell qui directrice
de l'institut pour l'économie locale
et si sur la base de deux vastes études
qui est le fait qu'elle rapporte
statistique l'acquis ont été confirmés
par ailleurs cette semaine par un ancien
ministre français
dans un article paru je me sais plus
dans quel publication met donc cette
statistique locustes pour chaque emploi
créé par amazon deux emplois perdus dans
l'économie locale ou régionale
encore là ça vient pas de nous ce sont
des témoignages rapportés par nos
experts et donc vous voulez faire quoi
avec ce film là quel impact vous
souhaitez avoir ben je pense que c'est
important de se rendre compte à quel
point on est en train de vivre une
transformation sociale qui est dû à la
présence dans nos vies de ces géants
numérique lot dont amazon et c'est
important de se questionner sur les
enjeux rattachés à leur présence et vers
où ils nous amènent collectivement et
qu'elles sont encore les leviers ne
contrôle démocratique qu'on peut exercer
sur eux
et puis c'est un peu cela la crainte
avec laquelle on terme je peux vendre
l'épanchement du film mais on termine le
film avec un compte de précaution et une
étude de code de seattle et de l'action
de siad d'amazon dans sa propre ville de
6 à tort de la ville qui lui a permis de
devenir une si grande et forte compagnie
et si vous voyez vous allez voir que
salaires à l'emploi et à ses trajets que
moi j'avais vu mais découvrez le punch
ça vous intéresse montréal québec et
ottawa 11 ans le film alexandre golden
ball club portland en oregon en oregon
salutations aux gens d'horizons ce soir
merci bien merci que pensez vous